[Music]
thank you dear me yes I'm going to be
speaking about node
um so welcome everybody to note computer
and thanks for attending to my talk I
will be talking about new and exciting
features in node.js
um a little bit about me I come all the
way from Colombia South America it took
me a while to get here but I'm very
happy to be in this beautiful place with
all of you I'm head developer Advocate
at fusebit which is a company that does
Integrations for developers and and I'm
a community leader speaker energy is
evangelist vlogger dancer and even
though my last name is parody I am not
really good at making jokes
unfortunately
and this is my Twitter list party and
fusby Twitter if you wanna have any
questions or if you want to chat you can
contact me there
so these are the five features we're
going to see today that you should
definitely try so the first one is test
Runner then we're going to see watch
stream accessories argument parsers and
undichi and raise your hand here who has
used these five features
yeah a few of them nice who has used
three of them
one
uh cool most of you so in this talk you
will have a basic understanding of these
features so you can get started and take
advantage of them
so the first one is test Runner
so we can all agree that tests are very
important but before no check is version
18 there was no third party there was
not like a test Runner out of the box
that supported node.js so developers
needed to use third-party testing
Frameworks such as mocha or just to do
unit testing but using a third-party
framework can add some complexity to do
your environment configuration cicd
workloads and maintainers overhead and
also it could be challenging which tool
to choose because some of those
Frameworks are like very great to set up
very quickly with minimum effort but
they can they don't have a sync testing
or Auto mocking or they're not very
complete and there are other Frameworks
that are the opposite they have
everything they're very complete they
have a sync testing automarking but
they're not as easy to set up so yeah it
has this straight UPS
so every developer to do tests in
node.js they needed to install its own
test Runner so it just just made sense
to create its own third Runner inside
node.js core and by doing this the
intention was to enable a limited subset
on the functionality provided by
monsters Frameworks in a library manner
so all of you can get started very
quickly you don't have to install
anything and you just add functionality
a stop as is needed
so how does this work
in short words you can do test energies
without any npm packages and you can use
the module node test and dashless test
to do some basic searching and matching
in test files
is recommended to do assertion with the
module node assert
and just as a fun fact they took
Inspirations of building their own test
Runner by dinner because Dino has its
own test Runner so the people of node.js
were like well I guess we can also have
our own test Runner well I think they'd
be exactly say it like that but kind of
and also they took inspiration for happy
lab for mocha and jest but in just it
actually took Inspirations of things not
to do in a test runner for example
injecting Global variables automatically
and execute
even
oops
hello oh yeah it's back to normal and
execute code in different contexts
because it can be it can have inexpected
results and outputs
so
I'm going to show you very quickly how
the test Runner works
so here we have the most basic test we
have tests from node test and assert for
from inside and we're just saying that
noteconf is a cool camp and we just
testing the business
true
so if we do
we just see that one test passed and
it's all good and now all of this is
inside node.js we don't have to install
anything which is super cool and for
example if we if we want to see how it
fails we just see
now it's gonna be the boring curve and
what we just see that it fails this is
the actual and respected and yeah we
have some warnings and some choice so
yeah this is very cool
and you can also skip test doing this
skip option with messages and this test
will be skipped and you can also do soup
test so here we're just measuring that
one is strictly equal to one and two is
strictly equal to two
and for more advanced functionality you
can do module interception with the
modules of proxycline and smog let's the
spine and stubbing with cinnamon and
Standalone snapshot with Snapchat
assertion and just with everything in
node.js that it's still experimental is
recommended to not be used in production
and just like as any test Runners
promise projection error drawing dog
don't call back not invoke they're all
treated as failures and you can use no
test as the module and run the test with
node and the file name
and also you can do no dash dash test
more options to run multiple files
at once
so the second feature is watch this is
super exciting I really like this one is
automatically restarting the node
application when it detects file changes
so last year no juice tweeted about
which single tool have you found to be
the most useful in your day-to-day
JavaScript authoring experience and a
lot of people replied
an old man
because it has 5.2 million weekly
downloads
so
basically what
The Watchman we watch the entry point of
any required or important module so you
don't have to stop your server and start
again once you file changes if you just
do note dash dash watch index your
application will automatically
refresh just as using node man
and you can use dash dash watch path to
see which path is being
observed
also this new flag cannot be combined
with the flag check eval and interactive
on the repo it just won't work
so that's it now you can use note watch
watch index or your file name to start
watching your files without having to
install anything but actually you cannot
use it yeah it's going to be ready like
in a couple of days so yeah
extreme aspect source
so is basically now you can use map
filter and reduce inside streams
so streams have a reputation of being
very hard to work with and even harder
to understand but they are one of the
fundamental concepts that powers no JS
applications
they are data handling metal used to
read or write input into output
sequentially so they're very good for
re-w writing or reading files for
network communications for any
end-to-end information exchange and what
makes a stream unique is that instead of
having all the files loaded into the
memory all at once like in the
traditional way
streams are very powerful because they
can read chunks of data piece by piece
and processing its content without
keeping it all into memory so this makes
string extremely efficient to work with
large data set or a big file because for
example a file size can be larger than
your free memory of a space so this
makes impossible for to file to be
processed because there is not enough
memory so this is where streams comes to
the Rescue by having a small chunks of
data you can be able to work with a big
amount of data and read files
so for example uh Netflix or YouTube or
other streaming services what they do is
instead of giving you all the content
and ones they give you the small pieces
of data so users can start consuming
straight away so that's why it's called
streaming services
but streams are not only good for large
files but they also give you the power
of compostability in our code and
designing with compostability in mind
means that you can have different
combinations of components and to have
the exact same output
so uh we know JS you can create this
composibility using streams by paping
data into another
and you'll be wondering why people
should use the streams well mainly for
two reasons one is memory efficiency and
the second one is time efficiency memory
efficiency because it takes
um is more efficient for the memory
because you don't have to load all the
files into memory at once to start
processing it and time efficiency
because it takes significantly less time
to start processing a file as soon as
you have it instead you have to have all
the payload to process it and there are
four types of streaming node.js
free travel writable which are extremes
that you can grade data data and with FS
create street right stream you can write
data into streams with readable you can
read data from each chunk of streams and
I'm going to show an example I'm I'm
going to actually use the readable
streams
and with FS create read streams this is
how you can read data from Steam from
streams and all content and everything
duplex is both writable and readable and
transform is that you can modify or
transform a file
that is being written or written for
example an instance of file compression
you can write compressed data and read
the compressed data
but streams has been around for a while
right but what is new and what is
exciting is that now you can use map
filter and reduce inside of each chunk
of a stream so let's see how
this works
so here we have readable which is one of
the four types of strings that I just
explained from node string streams and
resolver which help us with the DNS
promises
oh okay
[Music]
um
and we have a chunk of readable and
we're just reading this for numbers and
we're going to map those four numbers to
be multiplied by two and we're just
going to cancel log base so this is how
we read data from streams and we map it
and resolver here there's another
example we are reading from these three
web pages node.js nodeconf View and fuse
bit and we're just going to map those
three web pages and see they're DNA
result and how long it takes
so you can just do node
so this is it we can see how we've been
how streams are being mapped and the
results of those two web pages three web
pages
on filter
is very similar it is a very similar
example so we're just doing uh imported
readable resolver and we have these for
numbers and we're going to filter by the
number that is bigger than two and we
just printed out is three and four
and also here we're just reading the
same three web pages and we filter by
like the web pages are takes more than
60 milliseconds and we're just going to
print that in the console log
and reduce
we just have readable and we are having
these four numbers one two three four
and we're just going to do a reduce like
we're going to sum all of these numbers
and if you just do
now we reduce
it 10. so this is very cool
before you couldn't do that but now you
can do map filter and reduce in streams
okay the next one is argument parsers
so now you can part CLI arguments
so there was a really long discussion
inside node.js of how there were
multiple modules that handle parsing of
CLI for example Commander JS and yards
if to use to create programs inside
Clive
and yeah like the not just contributors
were like this is very useful a lot of
people use it maybe we should have it
inside node core
because for example Commander had 93
million weekly downloads uh Commander
just looks after parsing the arguments
into options and command arguments
displays usage error for problems and
implements the help system
and the Arts it has 70 million weekly
downloads like just a few weeks that I
checked and it helps you build
interactive command line tools but
parsing arguments and generating An
Elegant user interface
so now we you feel that parts are
modules uh we we see that this was
merged a few months ago and as we can
see in the description it adds util
Parts RS helper for higher level
commands like argument parsing instead
of interacting with process
our agv directly so it takes the
expector arguments and returns a
structured object with the parse options
so how does the parser work so it does
not execute functions it does not check
for types not typescript not anything
like that it doesn't allow you to Define
types and sub commands kind of take
options that are distinct from the main
commands or only the main command Motors
and dash dash would signal the end of
the options that are parse into the
parser
so let's see how the parser works
so
um important parts are for node util and
here I just have four options so the
name nationality dancer and gamer and we
just parsing those options and print it
in the console log
to see this we just do node
and then
and then I just do name
Liz dash dash nationality
Colombian
dancer I like to dance but I am not a
gamer so I'm not going to pass any
anything there so if we do this we can
see all the
Sprinter here in the CLI so this is also
very cool
and
as you can see this is how you if you
want to have the exact same output
before you will have to do all of this
with with process that our RGV and yeah
in more complicated you have to replace
and display it and this can have uh it
open the doors for vulnerabilities and
bugs and it's more complex but now you
can see it's way more clean and easy and
you can parse those arguments in a
better way
and another cool thing is that the
native module is not going to replace
the 16 packages instead it will Empower
them to easily catch those CLI arguments
and perform complex operations this was
said by Eric Wendell
and finally ondichi ondichi is a spec
compliant HTTP 1.1 client that is
written from scratch and represents the
evolution of the node.js HTTP stack
so I really like the documentation
because
11 in Italian and then because it's HTTP
1 1 is 11 and on the chain and it's also
a reference of stranger things
so you'll be wondering why undichi like
node.js has already HTTP stack that
works very well and it's all good people
use it so why to refresh and create
something all the way from scratch
the reality is that the HTTP stack in
node.js have some fundamental design
issues that are impossible to resolve
without breaking the API there are
certain bugs and performance bottlenecks
that will affect the majority of the
users but in the client and in the
server
so the thing behindichi decided to
create a fast reliable spec compliant
HTTP client for node.js
some important features about lundichi
is that it keeps Alive by default so you
don't have to install a keep a live
agent you have lifo scheduling which is
last in first out that is very good for
minimizing the time errors
timeout errors no pipeline by default
but you can configure your own Pipeline
and has limited connections and can
follow ready redirects and opt in
so
there are important things to understand
about Unity like mocking redirects and
proxy but because of the length of this
talk I'm just going to talk about
marking
um because in the cheap rain bands HTTP
Primitives and relies directly on socket
mocking approaches like knock won't work
but luckily for all of us only cheat
comes with its owned built-in mugs so we
can test against on the Chain so I'm
going to do an example with dogs
let's see how this works
so here we are requiring requests from
um instead of http
and we're just going to get a breed of
dogs that we're going to see this
webpage the list
all the breeds of dogs
and and also we're going to get some
images of those dogs so we get those
images and if there is an error we just
throw the error
so this is the dog client
um on the test
we can see this is the test for the dogs
we we just get hit the first test we
just see that it returns a list of the
breeds
and the second test we just says we're
just looking for the images of the dogs
and yeah and then we just catch if there
is an error or anything so we just have
two tests
of the dogs and finally
foreign
monk agent is the basic entry point of
the mocking system so this is how you
import it and then we have intercept
that is build that is used to build the
marks we have the path and the method
and the reply and finally we just
checked there is a image pad is valid
and we will have the message and some
images of the darks
um
yeah
we checked the the image is valid and
some to check for errors
and if you just do
oops hold on
well it was working a few moments ago
but this is basically how you do mock
inundichi
thank you
and because we're talking about pictures
with dogs this is my dog I found him in
a lake it was very tiny and very little
but now he's very big he grew up as big
as a cow he's gigantic
and some conclusions about exciting
features I know Js
is that first we the
contributors and node.js are always
looking to improve the runtime as we can
see with these five exciting features
that I just presented but there's other
exciting and experimental features that
you should check out out like a
sinkhooks diagnostic channels Trace
event web creature API women's trips API
and wasi that is webassembly system
interface
um so this is it thank you very much and
thank you for the organizers of this
conference and also for the node.js
contributors that are always looking to
create and make node.js better this is
my email my Twitter if you want to
contact me and I hope you enjoyed the
rest of the conference thank you